let's say that we have the vector
3 2
we know that we can express this as a
weighted sum of the unit vectors in two
dimensions or we could view it as a
linear combination and you could view
this as 3 times the unit vector in the x
direction which is 1 0
plus 2 times the unit vector in the y
direction which is 0 1 and we can graph
3 2 by saying okay we have three unit
vectors in the x direction this would be
one right over there that would be two
and then that would be three
and then we have plus two unit vectors
in the y direction
so one
and then 2
and then we know where our vector is or
what it would look like the vector 3 2
would look like
would
look like this
now let's apply a transformation to this
vector and so let's say we have the
transformation matrix i'll write it this
way
2 1
2 3.
now we've thought about this before one
way of thinking about a transformation
matrix is it gives you the image of the
unit vectors and so instead of being
this linear combination of the unit
vectors it's going to be this linear
combination of the images of the unit
vectors when we take the transformation
what do i mean well instead of having
three one zeros we are now going to have
three
two ones instead of having two zero ones
we're now going to have two
two threes
so i could write it this way
let me write it this way the image
of our original vector i'll put a prime
here to say we're talking about its
image is going to be 3
times instead of 1 0 it's going to be
times
2 1 vectors that's the image of the one
zero unit vector under this
transformation
and then we're gonna say plus
two
instead of zero ones we're gonna look at
the image under the transformation of
the zero one vector which the
transformation matrix gives us and that
is the two three vector
two
three
and we can graph this if we have three
two ones and two two threes what i could
do is overlay
this extra grid to help us so this is
two one that's one two one
that is two two ones going here and then
we have three two ones right over here
so there's three two ones
let me do this in
this color this part right over here is
going to be this vector the three two
ones
is going to look like
that
and then to that we add two two threes
so this is going to see two and then
three so this is going to be
one two three and then we have two two
threes so we end up
right over there
and so let me actually get rid of this
grid so we can see things a little bit
more clearly and so we here we have here
in purple we have our original three two
vector and now the image is going to be
three two ones plus two two threes
so the image of our 3 2 vector under
this transformation is going to be this
vector that i'm drawing right here and
it looks when i eyeball it it looks like
it is the 10
9 vector and we can verify that by doing
the math right over here so let's do
that this is going to be equal to 3
times
2 is 6 3 times 1 is 3
and we're going to add that to
2 times 2 is 4 two times three is six
and indeed you add the corresponding
entries six plus four is ten and three
plus six is nine
and we're done the important takeaway
here is that any vector can be
represented as a linear combination of
the unit vectors now when we take the
transformation it's now going to be a
linear combination not of the unit
vectors but of the images of the unit
vectors and we saw that visually and we
verified that mathematically